hey 42 here some things in life are so
Universal we forget just how strange
they really are take sleep as a prime
example the average person spends about
26 years in the Land of Nod which is
significantly more time than we dedicate
to any other activity
just think about that for a second no
matter how much we like to carbon about
carb DM and living life to the full the
single thing we do most with our limited
time on Earth is lie down unconscious in
a darkened room just in case that wasn't
a big enough waste of time whilst we're
over sleep are highly Advanced brains
activate nonsense mode Conjuring up
visions of what it would be like to be
chased through your hometown by a giant
parakeet with the face of Melania Trump
despite its inherent weirdness sleep is
probably the most universally popular
activity of all time seriously how many
people have you met who actively dislike
sleeping I'm willing to bet the answer
is a nice round zero sleep is the drug
we're all addicted to the Oblivion we
welcome with open arms nonetheless for
The Unlucky few who suffer from serious
Sleep Disorders getting into bed can be
a truly terrifying experience Sleep
Disorders also known as parasomnia's
Manifest in Myriad forms people with
narcolepsy fall asleep constantly during
the day Sleepwalkers wander about when
they should be tucked up in bed and
people with so-called nocturnal Eating
Disorders raid the fridge and go to town
on last night's leftovers all whilst
fast asleep but of all the ways your
sleep can go south perhaps the scariest
and strangest is something known as
sleep paralysis
now I've just listened to an amazing
book it's called the human Edge it's by
Greg orm and it talks about what skills
you can learn to safeguard you from the
coming AI job apocalypse it's a
fascinating guidebook on how we can all
take steps now to ensure our futures are
prosperous but I listened to it on
blinkist which reduces the most amazing
books into 15-minute bite-sized chunks
each blink on blinkist contains the most
important ideas from the book in
question so you're getting all the best
bits and the most powerful insights
without having to spend days reading the
full thing they have over 5 000 titles
from 27 categories and now you can
create a space with friends and family
where you can add share and recommend
titles from the blinkers Library all in
one place right in the app as a premium
user you can create multiple spaces with
the same people or with new ones to
create your blinkist space simply tap on
the spaces icon in the bottom right
corner of the screen and tap create
space type in the name of your space and
then tap share and create space now you
can tap on invite to invite people and
start sharing title recommendations and
exchanging ideas there's a world of
information out there but like me you
probably don't have eternity to absorb
it all and that's where blinkist comes
in so go ahead and get 25 of blinkist
annual premium start your seven day free
trial by clicking the link in my
description box below and thanks to
blinkist for sponsoring this video check
the link below to subscribe
by some estimates up to 50 of the
population will experience sleep
paralysis at some point during their
lives so you may already know what I'm
talking about if not allow me to explain
the full Terror of this particularly
petrifying parasomnia sleep paralysis
can occur either whilst falling asleep
or waking up either way the primary
symptom is the same despite being fully
conscious and able-bodied the sufferer
suddenly finds himself unable to move or
speak it can last anywhere from a few
seconds to several minutes either way
you are a captive within your own
corporeal confines
waking up to find you've become a
quadriplegic for no apparent reason is
disturbing enough but things only get
worse from that because this unnerving
paralysis is usually accompanied by a
whole host of other spooky symptoms at
the milder end of the spectrum are
headaches feelings of numbness or
tingling and weird disembodied noises
including pops fangs hisses or even
whispered voices
at the really bloody terrifying end of
the spectrum around 75 percent of people
experience intense hallucinations
accompanied by extreme fear some feel
like they're floating several feet in
the air Exorcist style whilst others
feel as though an unseen assailant is
trying to drag them out of bed
probably the most infamous symptom of
sleep paralysis is a sensation that
there's a malevolent presence in the
room with you for some people this looks
just out of sight but in many cases it
takes the form of some kind of demon
sitting on the sofa's chest slowly
suffocating them or even sexually
assaulting them whilst paralysis
prevents them from fighting back
experiencing paralysis for yourself this
probably all sounds like a load of
nonsense but the disorder is well
documented with strikingly similar cases
reported all over the world for
centuries in fact here is sleep
paralysis depicted in an oil painting
from 1781. obviously it's bloody
terrifying and it's obviously been
haunting mankind for hundreds of years
if not longer but what actually causes
it and why do people experience such
eerily similar hallucinations
before the Advent of modern medicine it
was widely believed sleep paralysis was
paranormal in nature caused by the
malevolent spirits that so often seemed
to accompany it the specific entity
responsible varied across cultures in
Egypt they blamed Jinn in Bangladesh an
unfriendly ghost called Baba and in
Brazil an old woman with long claws
known as pisadira German and Slavic
folklore point the finger at a
goblin-like creature known as mare that
sits on your chest in the night causing
bad dreams that's actually where we get
the word nightmare from these days we
explain sleep paralysis with science
rather than spirits but truthfully it's
still poorly understood despite its
unsettling nature sleep paralysis is
ultimately harmless as the paralysis
Fades and the hansi demons descend into
the Shadows there are no lasting
negative effects whatsoever for that
reason Beyond Simple curiosity there's
less incentive to cure it and there's
very limited research on the topic the
prevailing theory is that it's caused by
a malfunction in the waking up process
you're probably familiar with rapid eye
movement or REM sleep the phase in which
you dream several things happen to your
body during REM sleep your heart rate
Rises your blood pressure increases and
as the name suggests your eyes move
rapidly but you also experience
something called remitonia a near total
paralysis of the body caused by the
inhibition of the brain's motor neurons
when everything's working as it should
atonia is an important part of REM sleep
stopping you from physically acting out
your dreams it's thought that sleep
paralysis occurs when something goes
wrong and remitonia either kicks in too
early or wears off too late but whilst
that would explain the paralysis bit of
sleep paralysis it doesn't account for
all the other weirdness the shared
hallucinations and sex offender demons
and there's no scientific consensus as
to why people from such different
cultures and time periods have all
experienced such strikingly similar
hallucinations during sleep paralysis
sufferers feel completely conscious but
may be in a kind of transitional State
between sleep and wakefulness
sufficiently awake for conscious thought
yet still sleepy enough for dreams to
intrude on reality essentially these
weird hallucinations are waking
nightmares as for why they're so similar
from one person to the next that might
have something to do with your
instinctive response to suddenly
discovering you've become Stephen
Hawking defied overnight as fear and
panic spiral out of control and stress
hormones cause through your veins your
brain enters an emergency State called
hyper vigilance scanning the environment
for threats
considering the fact you're tucked up
safe and sound in bed threats are likely
to be thin on the ground but here's
where your dreams start to fill in the
gaps between experience and reality
during REM sleep breathing naturally
quickens becoming shallower which can
make you feel short of breath and cause
a sensation of pressure on your chest
but during sleep paralysis you're unable
to voluntarily control your breathing
you try to take a deep breath only to
find that you can't pressure and panic
start to build but your brain can't
explain why so you just dream up an
explanation instead ah there's obviously
a pervy demon sat on my chest now it all
makes perfect sense
it sounds crazy and it's safe to say
it's more of a hypothesis and scientific
fact but dreams do react to external
stimuli like smells and sounds all the
time you may have heard your alarm clock
in your dream before it actually wakes
you up
it's just in this case the external
stimulus the pressure on your chest and
an extreme sense of danger aren't
actually real
an alternative theory is that sleep
paralysis disrupts the parts of your
brain that store your own internal body
image creating the illusion of your own
body shape directly in front of you
if that's true the malicious and Trudy
you can sense in your bedroom is
actually you which somehow feels even
creepier as for the feelings of floating
or being dragged around your bedroom
that's likely caused by a spike of
activity in the cerebellum which is
responsible for coordinating movement
whilst exactly what causes sleep
paralysis remains Up For Debate a wealth
of anecdotal evidence has given us a
pretty good idea of what triggers it
you're more likely to suffer from sleep
paralysis if you're stressed tired have
an erratic sleep schedule or regularly
sleep on your back I guess that's most
of us then people who suffer from
insomnia or sleep apnea are also
significantly more likely to experience
sleep paralysis and there seems to be a
genetic component to it so if other
people in your family have it there's a
good chance you will too hey at least
that's something to talk about around
the dinner table so the next time you
wake up to find a highly aggressive old
woman sitting on your chest trying to
murder you take my advice try to wiggle
your toes if you can't just relax you
aren't in any danger and it'll all be
over in a couple of minutes or just
start screaming
thanks for watching